[Music]
tonight on et canada
ep canada celebrates pride with a very
special guest co-host what's her name
priyanca
we are catching up with our favorite
queer stars like lance bass who shares
how becoming a father to twins has
changed his life i've been able to spend
pretty much every single day with him of
their life and that is just a true
blessing then
dj shangela pierce gets sentimental
about the transformative two-time glad
media award-winning series we're here
sorry
plus the mom rihanna respects heather de
bro on how other parents can support
their queer children the truth is they
just want to be heard they just want
someone to listen accept them and love
them and that's it and
ronan rubenstein shares how his coming
out as bisexual has impacted others i
still to this day
get messages from people all over the
world all different ages explaining to
me what my story has meant to them
this is et canada celebrates pride
welcome to a special edition of et
canada i'm dallas dixon and we have a
very special guest co-host she's an icon
hi priyanka hi dallas what's my name i
can't believe we're taking over e.t
canada i am so excited me too tonight et
canada celebrates pride which we love to
do all year long and we are chatting
with lgbtq plus stars who are out loud
and proud and the community's allies who
are making a difference let's kick
things off with lance bass who is of
course part of one of the most popular
boy bands of all time in sync
oh yeah who didn't grow up a fan and i
may have always had a little crush on
him can i say that really
yeah ooh
dallas is so unprofessional whatever
free but not only is lance an iconic
entertainer he is a husband and most
recently became a father to twins
we can now officially call him a daddy
i grew up in the south in mississippi
and
you know you just grew up with those
family values and i came from a very
small town so you always dreamt of what
your future family would look like and
uh now that i'm able to you know to have
kids and build that family that i always
wanted
it's it's a dream come true i've been
able to spend pretty much every single
day with them of their life and that is
just a true blessing you have been
married to your very handsome husband
michael for many years now queer love is
real it's out there and it's never going
away
no no we're just more visible now which
is so great did you actually ever have a
point in your life where you thought
maybe none of this would ever happen for
you having a husband having kids i mean
once i was able to come out and be
myself
i really did feel that kids were not in
the stars for me i mean we had so much
opposition from everything we did we
were fighting for marriage equality so
kids were kind of the last thing i was
thinking of and you know you get told so
many times you're not supposed to have
kids that you start to believe it in a
way
eventually you kind of come out of that
and say no i need to be living the life
i want to live and you know screw
everyone else
that's the tea that is lance
i love it how does it feel to be
somebody that queer people feel
represented by just being yourself is so
powerful and i think you know if you're
in the public eye
you know you have a responsibility
especially as an lgbtqia person you know
you want to be a good representation and
now there's all flavors of the rainbow
you know being represented and doing
super great things in this entertainment
industry from musicians to actors i mean
there's this incredible a-list lgbt
artist right now and
it's so
crazy that that's only happened in the
last 10 years and so i cannot imagine
what is going to happen the next 10
years it is going to
i mean the whole industry is going to be
fabulous
thank you for being so
real
i i'm glad our kids have been exposed to
you
i'm i'm glad i exposed myself to them
best comedy series at the 2022 canadian
screen awards also the most nominated
series of the year can we just let that
sink in for a minute it's affirming it's
just it just affirms that these stories
matter that
you know
helping people see themselves is like a
super important and meaningful endeavor
awards like this this kind of
recognition i think just sends a clear
message that these stories will resonate
across
any and all gender race
age you know and
that's a really special thing i think to
talk about with a show like this and i
think that's
huge
that
people not involved maybe not queer
themselves not don't know a queer person
in their lives
saw this show
and
connected with the humanity of it
your father is coming on the next flight
he can find
he wants to fix you
what's beautiful about this show is that
yes there is queerness genderqueerness
uh
trans trans femininity
but they're people
mother i am not going up for them
you can
there are consequences to our actions
subby i know when we last spoke the law
it was kind of sinking in a bit being
the first south asian queer muslim actor
to star in a canadian primetime
television series what do you think that
means to queer people across canada i
think this is evidence that leads who
look like me can exist i do think that
where we're going is is to really see
our bodies our identities assuming more
kind of leadership roles on projects and
i'm really happy to be a part of a
movement that pushes that forward
[Music]
and i'm right over here
that's callum scott with this mega hit
cover of robin's dancing on my own
callum became an overnight sensation
while appearing on britain's got talent
and since then he's been creating some
of the best music out there yeah his
voice is unlike anyone else and i caught
up with the ridiculously handsome and
talented it's not fair callum right here
in studio to talk about his sophomore
album bridges and the beautiful
responsibility that he feels as the out
queer entertainer
if i can help
somebody's journey move along by being
my authentic self whether that's in
interviews whether that's on tv whether
that's
in music i feel like that's now my
responsibility i'm not a bearded by any
stretch it's a responsibility i hold
very dear to my heart i've had messages
from young guys young girls older people
any kind of situation being like you
helped me come to terms with who i am
you helped me to my family
and that to me is like magic that to me
is like
that's what i base my success on it's
those messages
[Music]
how does it feel to be releasing a
sophomore album and putting your 100
honest authentic self into that music
i feel incredibly proud that i'm in a
position where i can put my you know
authentic self out there and i can be
proud and you know show display that
kind of bravery and courage to to try
and encourage other people you know when
i was younger i think pride to me was
like a party as i've gotten older i
completely understand what pride
represents so at this point in your life
what does pride mean to you when i got
into music that's when i really
discovered
my sense of pride and i was like pride's
not just like you say the party and the
kind of the colors and the flags
it's about change and it's about
positivity and it's about embracing who
you are but i've got to say there is
change happening all the time and it's
so encouraging to see and it fills me
with pride
[Music]
love callum all right so the queer
community has always been influencing
mainstream fashion throughout history
yeah dallas and as androgynous fashion
takes more of a foothold on red carpets
we've gotta give a nod to the style
stars that have been holding it down
okay little nausea has kept our heads
turning in look after look after luck
[Music]
as one of the next generation's biggest
style stars the rapper has been pushing
fashion boundaries in his music videos
live performances and on red carpets
now we can't talk about androgynous
fashion without a nod to billy porter
his christian siriano moment at the 2019
oscars will forever go down in fashion
history and he's been one to watch on
the red carpet ever since as we see
stars like harry styles kid cudi and
jared leto continuing to push gender
bending style forward it's queer fashion
icons like billy that have helped pave
the way
from bella swan to lady die kristen
stewart has had an evolution for the
books and her fashion is no exception
as a chanel ambassador since 2013
kristen has been turning heads on red
carpets for years in looks that
perfectly combined french couture with
her own edgy aesthetic
[Music]
janelle monae has challenged fashion and
beauty standards for a minute
as a staple of the best dressed list
time and time again it's no surprise she
took home the board of directors tribute
at the 2017 cfdas
[Music]
and canada's own dan levy has been
serving david rose vibes on and off
shit's creek can you imagine this in
prison from valentino to tom brown to
custom levy dan levy has become a
fashion icon in the last few years and
we can't wait to see what looks he rocks
next
[Music]
so many queer fashion icons all right
coming up a canadian icon ally deborah
cox shares a message to the lgbtq plus
community and dj shangela pierce talks
about the award-winning powerful series
we're here stay with us
[Music]
welcome back to this special edition of
et canada et canada celebrates pride now
the series we're here recently won its
second glaad media award for outstanding
reality program yeah priy i love this
show so much season three is coming this
is the real in reality tv and when i
caught up with our friend and one of the
stars that were here dj shangela pierce
the emotions couldn't be held back when
talking about the impact this series has
had on so many hallelu
drag is about empowerment we travel
across this country to take people from
who they are to what they can be
this project has always spoken directly
to my heart because i grew up in a small
conservative town and being able to have
the opportunity to travel around america
and amplify voices in small conservative
towns queer voices tell the stories the
struggles the triumphs all of that is a
gift to me going into these small
conservative towns i must imagine for
you by the time you leave you just must
feel this incredible sense of wow we did
that we changed some people's
perceptions of the queer community and
the art form of drag i'll never forget
after evansville indiana
[Music]
sorry
he's had to exist in this world of fear
what made you want to do drag here i
don't want to hide no more i don't want
to conceal no more me and luscious my
makeup artist sat in the car and we just
cried
and we were just so happy for case from
the time that we had met him when we
first got there just seeing him blossom
and then seeing you know him come out
and embrace all of who he was you know
through his drag character and through
the stage performance and hearing that
audience like
in a place where he always felt isolated
you know
and afraid so many times to have the
courage to be on stage and to perform
and to feel that spirit of community
that he didn't know existed
[Applause]
and to see that
and know that we had a a part in that
was like
it was just beautiful
i love shangela someone else we love is
ronan rubinstein star of super popular
series 9-1-1 lone star yeah pre and when
i caught up with him to talk about his
queer character tk he also spoke about
coming out as bisexual in his own life
and what that bi visibility has meant to
people all around the world
[Music]
it was a massive weight off my shoulders
more in the sense of
i i could be transparent with my close
family and friends and that to be
completely honest was not easy you know
certain people in my life are not there
anymore because of this and certain
people in my life i think our
relationship has gotten stronger i still
to this day get messages from people all
over the world all different ages
explaining to me what my story has meant
to them 9-1-1 lone star what an
incredible show tk has become a fan
favorite welcome home tk
[Music]
i can only imagine the amount of
messages that you get from people saying
i feel singing it's just unbelievable
man and it's every single day i hear
from somebody new you know reaching out
and telling us what the show means to
them and what tk means to them i think
the biggest one that i could sort of
think of it always stands out is i sort
of call him my real-life tk he's a queer
firefighter from canada he was very much
closeted did not feel safe and
comfortable telling his peers he saw
that tk became a paramedic and it
inspired him to become a paramedic so
now
he moved from a rural town in canada to
vancouver where now he's fully himself
he's out to his firehouse and now he's
on the verge of going to medical school
and wants to become a doctor so it's
truly changing people's lives and
on such a deeper level than just being
you know a character on a tv show it's
it's really really really unbelievable
love ronan's journey all right soon to
come one of the moms rihanna looks up to
heather de brogle talks about supporting
her two queer children and shares advice
for other parents and the bachelor star
colton underwood talks his polarizing
coming out story and
recent engagements
hey everybody it's your girl debra cox
happy pride some of my best moments at
pride have been right here in toronto
for world pride epic epic epic amazing i
want to send you all so much love happy
pride
love you
[Music]
colton underwood first grabbed our
attention on the bachelor season 23 and
since then colton became the first lead
in bachelor franchise history to come
out yeah pre i caught up with colton to
talk about his recent engagement and
just how he felt after sharing his truth
and coming out to the world on good
morning america
i've ran for myself for a long time i've
hated myself for a long time and
i'm
gay oh i felt like a
million trillion pounds were lifted off
my shoulders it was a secret that i
guarded and protected and lied for
for so many years to be able to just
finally shed all of that and start sort
of peeling off these layers of
protection and armor that i put up was
the feeling that i'm still experiencing
you know i had been through it as far as
you know the media sort of telling my
story for me for so many you know so
many years i just had to remind myself
of that show myself grace and patience
and
love and surround myself i had a great
support system with my friends and my
family too we need to celebrate your
engagement congratulations
how did you know jordan was the one it
wasn't forced it was unexpected and i
mean just like the feeling that you know
i had and he had it just was undeniable
what would you say jordan has brought
into your life other than love that
maybe you didn't have before i just say
balance i mean finding balance both in
professional life and personal life and
also just someone to to have a good time
with and then i can be as authentic and
as true to myself as i could be
heather de bruyne is one of the most
popular women on reality television but
beyond being a badass businesswoman
she's also an incredibly supportive
mother to her two queer children max and
cat yapri even new mom rihanna gave her
props in a recent l interview saying
just love the way that she just allows
her kids to be who they are and that's
really inspiring to me and when i caught
up with heather she spoke about how
other parents can support their queer
children too
at first i was very insecure and unsure
of my sexuality and until i really
started to get support from my family
and the people around me i think i
really started to
become proud for me with all the drama
and the nonsense of being on shows like
this those scenes
are so special and it's not like hey
look at me what look at what a great mom
i am looking it's not about that it's
about saying
we're doing the best we can here's how
we're doing it talk about it with your
kids accept your kids if no one else is
loving you or taking care of you at the
very least the people that brought you
into this world and created you
should be there for you and i'm proud of
you i'm proud that you know who you are
and and if you want to fly a flag and
fly a huge one in your room fly the damn
flag
but i have seen some people say even
former castmates of mine say things like
oh you shouldn't bring this on for a
storyline let me be very clear about
something i'm not bringing anything on
as a storyline this is actually my life
which is the point of a reality show so
the thought that there's children out
there whose parents don't even accept
them just kills me
it just kills me come to my house i
truly do not believe i would be in this
position today if my parents also were
not supportive and accepting when i came
out i know how great it felt to be able
to go to my parents and discuss anything
yeah i'm very lucky that way i didn't
come from a family like that the family
i came from didn't talk about anything
and so you know for me it was of the you
know utmost importance to create a
family that could talk to each other
what do you think you can say to other
parents out there who may be struggling
with accepting their own queer children
man just listen the truth is they just
want to be heard they just want someone
to listen accept them and love them and
that's it
[Music]
thanks for watching everybody how fun
was this it was amazing don't forget
pride is celebrated all year round here
at et canada head to etcanada.com
and check out our pride hub and as i
always like to say
just be gay
that's right own who you are and let's
celebrate our individuality and
differences we now leave you with lady
gaga's iconic anthem born this way happy
pride everybody
[Music]
[Music]